Cam Newton has a dream job in Carolina
he's the quarterback in the Panthers he
said he wants to stay what you need to
know this morning is we don't know what
to know about the Carolina Panthers and
Cam Newton because the people who are
running that team are keeping their
cards very close to the vest last week
it was general manager Marty her knee
who was evading questions about the
future of Cam Newton this week it's
David Tepper
the owner of the team who was asked
about Cam Newton status with the
organization Newton has said he will
absolutely play for the Panthers in 2020
and David tempers position is there's
nothing to talk about
until Cam Newton is healthy but don't
take my word for it as if you ever would
here is Panthers owner David Tepper on
Tuesday addressing the future of Cam
Newton and Carolina I'm not a doctor you
know and I said it a million times he's
he is he healthy and how does it I mean
he's not a doctor so you know there's a
lot of different things can happen but
first is is he healthy tell me that and
then we can talk you know it's funny the
I'm not a doctor thing works for most
people but when you are rich enough to
buy the opinion of any doctor in the
world or every doctor in the world I
don't know that I'm not a doctor flies
I'd like to think by now David Tepper
multi billionaire owner of the Panthers
has had a doctor give him some idea as
to when /ev Cam Newton is going to be
healthy again big cat I think with the
Panthers they are at a point where
there's fatigue when it comes to the
constant questions about Cam Newton's
health and the reality then he never
seems to be healthy he's either
rehabbing an injury or he's got a new
injuries playing through and and I think
that at some level the organization just
has decided we need to move on we can't
do this anymore so I agree with you
there I do think that there's the tone
that they're going to move on from Cam
Newton I don't think that's smart
I think Cam Newton if healthy is
probably still a top-ten quarterback you
just don't let a guy like that walk out
the door when you don't have someone to
replace him like they tried the Kyle
Allen thing last year it didn't really
work they tried the will Grier thing it
didn't seem like it works
who knows if he gonna can be the guy you
know he's obviously just a rookie so Cam
Newton if you're trying to win right now
if you're trying to say hey we have
Christian McCaffrey still who is you
know one of the top three impact players
in the league right now you know was was
in the MVP discussion last year up until
the the season kind of fell apart let's
let's still try to go for this thing
let's try to put this thing back
together with Cam Newton one last run I
don't think they're going to I think
that's the smart thing to do but what
this comment from the owner says to me
is he's really just saying I need cam to
show up and I need to talk to him
because I'm not a doctor line you're
exactly right he knows what's going on
with Cam he's gotten opinions on he's
probably gotten multiple opinions on it
but he probably hasn't heard it from cam
so having Cam Newton show up to OTAs
having him show up to offseason you know
work out and non-mandatory lifts and
being a presence in the facility that's
what this message kind of sentence out
there to me like he's saying hey cam
come show up let's talk let's see if
you're okay you tell me you're okay and
we'll assess from there right now I'm
just talking to a bunch of doctors even
though I'm not a doctor and trying to
surmise whether you're healthy or not
well and I think another part of this is
this notion of buying into the new
regime the new process in Carolina a lot
of changes have been made the only coach
that Cam Newton has ever known at the
NFL level is now in Washington Matt rule
from Baylor is in and when rule was
introduced David Tepper answered
questions from the media and he was
asked about cams future and he went
straight into this concept of the
importance of having everyone buy in
which implies that maybe there's concern
that the franchise quarterback who has
only played for Ron Rivera may not buy
and here's a bottom line he's under
contract for one more year at about 19
million dollars incredibly tradable
because it's ridiculously below market
and there's a team in LA that needs to
start acting like it's in LA and has
already begun the process of moving
forward from Phillip Rivers he's gone
they've announced it and Tom telesco the
GM of the team said earlier this week
that that they liked their internal
options although it's not like he's
going to come out and say we want to
trade for Cam Newton that would not be
wise it would be tampering first of all
second of
it makes it more expensive to get him if
you make it known you want him but
that's the team that eventually should
be banging on the door of David Tepper
to try to get Cam Newton and I think
that one of the reasons the Panthers are
being coy is they want to see whether
it's the Chargers or someone else who
will show up and try to trade for Cam
Newton and then they assess their
options once they know what they can get
for Cam Newton they say they're being
very strategic and businesslike about
this that's one of the reason why David
Tepper has so much money he doesn't go
into these things recklessly he has a
plan and I think the plan is let's see
what's behind door number two by way of
what someone will offer us at some point
for Cam Newton yeah and looking right
now the Panthers obviously have the
seventh pick in the draft so you have to
ask yourself like are they gonna take a
quarterback are you sold on a
quarterback in that spot because I think
two is probably gonna go before that Joe
burrows gonna go one too the Cincinnati
Bengals are you going to find yourself
in a situation where you sell yourself
on a guy and just because you have the
seventh pick you're like alright while
we're up here we might as well take a
guy I don't know if that's the smartest
strategy I also think Mike throwing in
the element of a rookie head coach a guy
who's going from Baylor to the NFL like
having success right away and and
showing that you belong is important for
a guy like that we in Matt rule you're
paying him a lot of money
so if Cam Newton wants to play for the
Panthers and he wants to buy in I think
it would make it smart it would be a
smarter decision to keep him then send
him away and kind of have to figure out
this quarterback thing with that rookie
head coach and maybe throw away a couple
of years and possibly Matt Matt rule you
know what I mean like they do you know
how the NFL works if you start off in
the first two three years are not good
just because you don't have a
quarterback it could be it could be
curtains for you guys have no patience
the owner has no patience in the NFL so
that's an important piece to this puzzle
as well that I'm interested in well and
there's another piece to the puzzle that
no one may be willing to acknowledge yet
you mentioned how much they're paying
Matt rule blue the market apart as
relates to entry-level head coaches
especially for a guy who has one year of
NFL experience as an assistant offensive
line coach for the Giants into
12 Cam Newton is ridiculously underpaid
and it may be that Cam Newton's position
is I'm not going back onto a football
field until I rip up this 19 million
dollars and I'm due to make this year
and you give me a real contract that
reflects how the market has changed
since I last signed a long term
extension that replaced his rookie deal
I think that could be part of this too
and again nobody wants to be the bad guy
when it falls apart right no one wants
to be perceived as the reason why a
franchise quarterback leaves a team and
it very well could be that everyone
knows that this thing has come to an end
but they're trying to figure out the
best way to make it end
and if Cam Newton has said I want a new
contract I mean I don't know that you
know if I'm the Panthers and I'm keeping
Cam Newton I'm not given a new contract
I want to see what he does this year I
want to see that he's healthy and if it
doesn't work it doesn't work but if you
sign them to a new deal when it doesn't
work you're stuck with a huge cap hit
and a huge financial investment well
into the future
so that really is the question and like
how this whole thing is gonna play out
is will there be a team out there that
wants to sign Cam Newton to a long term
deal before he even steps back on a
football field because that's really
what's gonna end up happening right
wouldn't you think with the trade if
they trade Cam Newton to the Chargers
let's just throw that out there right
the Chargers are not gonna trade for Cam
Newton just thinking they might have a
one-year rental and then if he plays
well they're gonna he's gonna get to hit
the free agent market and walk away from
you know trading an asset for him so I
would assume that if Kenny didn't go
somewhere else in a trade there will be
a deal set for him to sign when he shows
up for at least the you know an extra
year or two contract extension that to
me is crazy like you said you got to see
what Cam Newton is right now because he
hasn't been healthy in a long time and
there's been a lot of weird stuff that
has gone on so making sure that you see
him before you sign the contract I guess
it's one of those situations where
there's always you know a sucker at the
table and someone is going to bite and
someone's going to say you know what
we'll take our chances here his shoulder
might never be the same but let's just
take our chances here because we need a
splash
yeah and you know what that is a very
real dynamic in this because even though
Cam Newton objectively should understand
why a team wouldn't want to make the
investment objectivity goes out the
window he's seeing all these other guys
that he looks at and says these guys
aren't as good as I am getting paid huge
money and here he is south of 20 million
Nick Foles is making 22 million a year
for crying out loud on the bench in
Jacksonville behind a six round draft
pick
so Cam Newton is going to insist I
believe on a new contract either from
the Panthers or from wherever he gets
traded and hey the charges look the
charges got to start acting like they're
in LA and the best way to act like
you're in LA is to get Tom Brady or Cam
Newton to be your quarterback and they
don't get Brady
I think Newton's a guy they need to get
and if they have to give a new contract
so be
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports